[Music]
in the Philosopher's Stone Harry is an
11 year old boy who's suddenly faced
with confusing and magical world one
minute he's sharing an awful vacation
with the Dursleys on hot on a rock an
island looks like a miniature Azkaban
and the next moment a slightly homeless
looking half giant is banging down their
door just thinking about it
I think Vernon Dursley reaching for his
gun is pretty reasonable this vacation
was of course just an attempt at getting
away from the Hogwarts letters that the
Dursleys kept destroying and could not
escape from it's the middle of the night
everyone sound asleep and Harry is
writing happy birthday to himself in the
dirt as you do the clock strikes
midnight then comes Hagrid who basically
just break and enters into their
vacation home sure why not he is a giant
giant man and no one even really knows
who he is I know that he needed to get
Harry his letter but he could have done
it a little bit more tactfully after all
the doses can be pretty awful people
but they probably don't deserve to think
that they're being murdered Vernon and
petunia might know Hagrid but Dudley
doesn't first things first
Hagrid delivers Harry his birthday cake
he explains that he sat on it and that's
fine because he probably only weighs 8
900 pounds Hagrid's primary reasons for
the visit were of course to deliver
Harry a birthday cake as well as his
Hogwarts letter
Harry begins to read his Hogwarts letter
finally and then begins to get reamed
out by Vernon and petunia for being
magic and having magical parents Vernon
insults Dumbledore and Hagrid makes a
very questionable threat towards him
with his umbrella during this time the
cake that was left unattended for a very
short period is being shoveled into
Dudley's mouth Hagrid seizes and wastes
no time
instantly flicking his umbrella and
giving him a pigtail okay so this bares
the question how is Hagrid able to
perform a magic in the presence of
muggles and be mad
on muggles and get away with it
knowingly using magic in a muggle
inhabited area or in front of a muggle
violate section 13 of the International
Confederation of warlock statute of
secrecy Harry was in a life-or-death
situation with the Dementors and got in
trouble for magic so how can hacker
break into their home give them pigtails
and walk away because Harry is such an
influential figure in the Wizarding
World
and because the Dursleys have taken such
extreme measures to keep him from
anything magic perhaps Hagrid was simply
able to take a few liberties with his
assignment at least as far as discussing
elements of the magical world in front
of muggles one thing that I know for
sure is that underage trace on young
Wizards doesn't usually begin until they
actually start at Hogwarts
so they likely wouldn't have been
keeping a super close watch on Harry
Hagrid is also barred from magic so
that's something to consider giving
Dudley a pigtail that he later had to
have surgically removed is definitely
excessive but I think that the worst
part about it is that Hagrid actually
meant to turn him into a pig entirely he
wasn't successful but the intention was
there this is reflected when he says the
following shouldn'ta lost me temper
Hagrid said ruefully but it didn't work
anyway meant to turn him into a pig but
I suppose he was so much like a pig
anyway there wasn't much left to do
Hagrid broke at least three Wizarding
laws assaulting a muggle one that's ten
years old using magic in front of
muggles and illegal magic I'd like to
say that the ministry knew and just
turned a blind eye for the day but
knowing how they are that's unlikely it
is more likely that Hagrid just broke a
lot of laws and doesn't care he is old
enough that he would no longer have the
trace and any sort of magical activity
that he performs would be harder for the
ministry to detect if that is the case
then it's likely that Harry didn't yet
have the trace either that's it for the
video until next time hurry hurry did
you put on able to cope with the fire
Dumbledore asked calmly
[Music]